we want to begin this hour by marking a
very special day in US history on June
19 1865 that's a hundred and fifty-five
years ago today none of us were there
the last group of enslaved people in
America were freed the occasion though
was bittersweet because it came two and
a half years after the Emancipation
Proclamation of 1863 which some states
were slow to recognize CBS News special
correspondent that's James Brown has the
story of the day that became known as
Juneteenth that month ad for the last
three years on taya and Michael McIntyre
have celebrated June 10th with their
four kids in their mostly white
California neighborhood what is it about
June 10th that you want people to know
it's not just a black holiday it really
is a celebration of freedom and that's
what America is about and so if you
celebrate the 4th of July
you absolutely should celebrate Jean
teenth as well
everyone the McIntyre's invite their
neighbors not only to celebrate but to
use it as a teaching moment we reached
out to the parents let them know what we
wanted to celebrate all of the parents
were okay with that and they sent the
kids down here a couple of couple of the
parents came as well I got text messages
from the parents and said thanks for
teaching my kid about that cool holiday
and they can't stop talking about
Juneteenth June teen stands for June
19th the day in 1865 when Union General
Gordon Granger finally arrived in
Galveston Texas to announce the
emancipation of slaves Texas had kept
approximately 250,000 black people
enslaved for two-and-a-half years after
the Emancipation Proclamation became law
in 1863 and the man who signed it
President Abraham Lincoln had been
assassinated two months before Granger
arrived can you imagine
so what June teeth is June 19th is the
acknowledgment and yes commemoration
that there were slaves that lasted two
more years and for them it was a
lifetime Texas congresswoman Sheila
Jackson Lee has been pushing to make
Juneteenth a national hot
day for two decades the potential of
having this national holiday opens a
whole world of discussion for America a
whole reckoning with a racism and the
systemic racism that permeates the
nation where do you sense legislatively
we are are we poised to see this come
across the finish line I do we are just
very pleased at the number of
co-sponsors and members who are
interested in being supportive in the
resolution that we already introduced we
have 204 co-sponsors it's delayed
freedom but it is the only recognition
of the original sin of this nation so
Juneteenth is an ability to tell the
story of slavery african-americans
haven't waited for a national
recognition to celebrate Juneteenth
since 1866
parades and barbecues have been a staple
of black communities from Houston and
San Antonio to Chicago and Little Rock
they have some really big
Juneteenth celebrations and I would love
to go out to one of those because I mean
there's thousands of people out there
back in California the McIntyre's feel
their small celebration is one way to
bridge the racial divide
during this tense moment in our history
my husband and I we took our children to
a peaceful protest and I found myself
walking with the fists in the air and
there was a movement that when I looked
around it wasn't just black people
holding their hands up and so that's why
I feel like there is some momentum
around Juneteenth James I have to say
first Bravo love the McIntyre's what a
great couple they are I've known about
Juneteenth for years and if occasionally
celebrated gone to some celebrations but
I can't honestly say to you that it's
something I consciously celebrated every
single year but it really feels like
we're in a moment this time with the
death of George Floyd and others it
seems to be giving added importance to
Juneteenth this year do you think so too
oh absolutely and sadly because of a
horrific event like
that many people are thinking about it
but the McIntyre's are a perfect family
example of that as they educate their
kids and the ones in the neighborhood
Gail look we understand that teaching
involves explanation and demonstration
and from that comes a practical
application and discussion and it's so
nice to see that the young people are
embracing that yes I think so too
many in corporate America are
recognizing Juneteenth including Viacom
CBS a company we work for but you know
in TV news business James we work on
holiday so I'm thinking now I know what
I'm going to take the rest of the day
off but a lot of corporations for the
first time this year are paying
attention I also think that's a good
thing and let me be clear as well to
Gail thank you for your honesty and
that's exactly what I'm doing today as
well to again amplifying on what
teaching is all about in the fact that
matter is all seven mountains of
influence in society whether it's arts
and entertainment business government
media we ought to all embrace it because
Gail it is shared history it really is
the president has raised a couple of
eyebrows if you looked at the Wall
Street Journal I know you've seen it
where he says that he made Juneteenth
famous nobody had heard of it before he
mentioned the the controversy in Tulsa
where and he moved his rally well that
certainly is not true but a lot of
people are learning about it for the
first time well keep in mind as the
album Patrick and I indicate it in that
peace album being my producer since 1866
people of color have been celebrating it
and a growing number I would think that
it stands on its own well now that you
know you know you can't ignore it any
longer James Brown always good to see
you